will and jada pinkett smith go out for a
day date marking an important milestone
jada and i have you know we weathered
some storms it's the first time they've
stepped out together since the infamous
oscar slap the couple was snapped
leaving the restaurant nobu in malibu
over the weekend yeah months later wills
all smiles as he flashes a peace sign
while jada is not far behind the actor
wears a navy polo tee and matching
baseball cap and the red table talk host
also keeps it casual
less is more for me
simple she dons a black jumpsuit hoop
earrings a pair of aviators with a
flannel tied around her waist with both
seemingly keeping it low key the
sighting also comes after will opened up
about his wife's role in the oscars
controversy
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations the slap stemmed
from chris rock's joke about jada's
shaved head a hairstyle she rocks
because she suffers from alopecia a hair
loss condition
so i thought i'd just share it so y'all
not asking any questions while many fans
speculated she encouraged her husband to
react physically
will set the record straight last month
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it
i'm sorry babe
and a message to chris will also
explained why he didn't apologize
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
um
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris i
apologize
to you
my behavior
was
unacceptable
i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
in the meantime will's got plenty of
people in his corner like his ex-wife
cherie zampino who recently offered an
update from the family's inner circle
well it's good i haven't noticed
anything different with our
communication you know what i mean
um he's you know he's a great he's a
he's a great man and he's human and he's
evolving just like the rest of us are
he's so kind to people and i just hope
that people give him that same grace and
kindness and love back that's that's
that's what i hope for him another one
of his supporters will packer who
produced the academy awards broadcast
i love the fact that he's being so
transparent about his process clearly he
is going through his own personal
rehabilitation he is being very public
and honest and open about his remorse
i'm pulling for him to continue his own
process but i think this is for him he
needs to do it and i wish you the best
brother
[Music]